If there's something strange, sleeping in your bed, let me tell you something.
If there's something weird, sleeping in your bed, let me tell you something.
Bustin' makes me feel good.
If you're seeing things, sleeping in your bed.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm invisible man, sleeping in your bed.
Let me tell you something.
Yeah, yeah, yeah Bustin', bustin', bustin'
Makes me feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good Feel good, feel good, feel good, yeah, yeah
If you're all alone, let me sleep in your bed.
Let me tell you something.
Sleeping makes me feel good.
I ain't afraid of no sleep.
I ain't afraid of no bed.
An invisible bed.
Freaky ghost bed.
Yeah, yeah, yeah
Botsen, bosem, bosem, bosem, bosem, bosem...
Makes me feel good.
Feel good.
Yeah, yeah.
Bosem, bosem, bosem, bosem, bosem...
Makes me feel good.
Feel good, feel good, feel good Yeah, yeah Bastin, bastin, bastin
Makes me feel good
Oop.
It's over.